Russia has begun A Renewed offensive in
eastern Ukraine many are calling it The
Battle for donbass but what does this
new phase mean for the larger conflict
and what is the human cost this is
Inside Story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program I'm Kim
vanell it's been nearly two months since
Russian forces invaded neighboring
Ukraine the conflict has killed
countless civilians and displaced
Millions now Moscow says it's shifting
its focus to the east where it's
increased its assault in the donbass
region the U.S British and Canadian
leaders have promised to send more
weapons to Ukrainian forces many say
this is a crucial stage of the conflict
and could lead to the breakup of Ukraine
we'll get to our guests in just a moment
but first this update from Assad bake
what Russia refuses to call a war has
now entered its second phase and it's
being dubbed the battle for donbass this
operation in the east of Ukraine is
aimed as was announced from the very
beginning to fully Liberate the danielsk
and Logan's republics and this operation
will will continue it is beginning I
mean another stage of this operation is
beginning and I'm sure this will be a
very important moment of this entire
Special Operation ukrainians caught up
in the fighting are forced to flee as
Russian forces Pummel cities and towns
Ukraine's President says Russia will not
be successful
intensiveness
the intensity of Fire by Russian troops
in the hakive direction in the donbass
and in the nepro petrosk region has
increased significantly the same as
before they consider ordinary
residential housing to be normal
military Targets in this war the Russian
army will forever inscribe itself in
world history as perhaps the most
barbaric and inhumane army in the world
Ukraine says it's repelled a number of
Russian attacks in the east
a second ultimatum issued by Russia for
Ukrainian soldiers in mariopol to
surrender has passed
Moscow had said the lives of the
soldiers inside the steel Works would be
spared if they see what it called
senseless resistance
[Music]
the United States and Western countries
are doing everything to drag out the
special military operation as much as
possible the growing supplies of foreign
weapons clearly signal the intention to
provoke the key regime to keep fighting
until the last Ukrainian
the European Union is considering more
sanctions on Russia we call on the
Russia we continue to call on Russia to
stop all the illegal and illegitimate
actions connected to its aggression
against Ukraine and when it comes to
next round of the sanctions I think the
EU highest Representatives the leaders
of the EU and also the representatives
of the member states very very clear
that we continue the work on further
sanctions and when the time will be
right they will be announced
so far calls for a ceasefire or the
threat of sanctions have not stopped
this war and although Russia may have
failed to take Keith the battle for the
East is when Russia cannot be seen to
lose Assad Al Jazeera
foreign
let's bring in our guests in Kiev we
have Helena yachenko a member of the
Ukrainian Parliament and Secretary of
the national presidential Council in
Moscow Pavel falgenhauer defense and
Military analyst for Nevada gazetta and
independent newspaper and in Brussels
Theresa Fallon director of the center
for Russia Europe Asia studies uh thank
you very much for joining us here on
Inside Story I'd like to start with you
uh Pavel falgenhauer if I may as the
military analyst what does this new
stage in the war what does it mean
um we'll just change of emphasis it's uh
Russia tried in the beginning of this
campaign to uh kind of Advance at the
same time on a number of different
separate directions it didn't work out
very well so now the Russia's reserves
and forces which are clearly not
adequate for such a job of attack moving
in all directions we'll be concentrating
in the particular area of the east south
Ukraine to achieve apparently Victory
there so now they began what's been
officially announced at least by the
Russian Prime Minister is a new stage
I've heard it described as a do-over I
don't know if you're familiar with that
but where you fail the first time you
try again a second time is that what
this is failure of the initial aims
therefore a recalibration a a new kind
of measure of what success means for
Russia in this war
well in the first week more or less of
the campaign in the South Russia
achieved quite a lot the forces broke
out of Crimea moved swiftly in different
directions captured a number of
Ukrainian big cities without much
resistance or with no resistance at all
across the nepper capture the bridge
over the Napper rather spectacular but
then that Advance kind of came to a halt
not enough reserves and now the
commander who is in charge of this
initial success in the South a general
Alexander wardnikov the commander of the
South Military district is become the
CNC of the whole operation he's given
more freedom more reserves and since
he's kind of the general of the month
from the Russian point of view who
achieved most successes it's called on
him to kind of achieve success of the
entire operation and well I will see
what he's going to do but of course
right now it's a very slow start for the
second stage it's I would say
preliminary action and very slow action
all right let's talk about what
you is going to do Helena yachenko
you're a member of the Ukrainian
Parliament you're in Kiev you're
Ukrainian what do you think that
Russia's President Putin wants with
donbass well first of all I want to
response on the on a light and Russian
propaganda that you just heard from the
man before first there is no operation
and don't call it operation because it
is war it's massive execution of
civilians who have nothing to do you
know with military guys
if you want to call torture
uh torturing children and operation if
you are calling these kind of things and
operation then I'm really sorry for you
because you know there is something
wrong with your head and with your moral
qualities
so this is work this is massive
execution of civilians this is torturing
of children this is raping woman and no
one in this world no one who has hurt
and who has mind in his head don't call
it operation it's a word and it's it's a
very bad thing that Russian occupants
that Russian Nazis are doing in Ukraine
and the situation is very tense
just uh yesterday I have reported on my
Twitter
that uh the situation in marivol is very
tense there are still a number of
civilians we are talking mainly about
women and children and in my opinion as
a mother of two children there is no way
that Russian soldiers can torturing can
sell in children there are a lot of
children a lot of mothers a lot of
mothers with newborn babies in mariopol
hiding in bomb shelves of as of style
and we hear that Russian soldiers have
orders to sell these people so Russians
have an order to sell children okay
currently I know that to all Arabic
mothers and all Arabic you know people
who are watching our show do you
consider that it is okay to sell and to
murder children do you imagine that your
children or you yourself will go through
this kind of nightmare this is what
Ukraine is going through I know that I
know that the mayor of Mario Paul has
said some 20 000 civilians have been
killed in Mario poll it hasn't been
verified but that is that is a shocking
number
um I need to move over to Brussels if I
may uh Theresa Fallon what do you think
that President Putin wants with Don boss
and and what do you make of I know the
European Council president Charles
Michelle is in Kiev today what do you
make of of Europe's response so far well
it appears that instead of working all
across Ukraine they want to focus on
donbass to have some sort of a success
story but even many others think that uh
with the May 9th deadline some people
think that because of the May 9th
Victory Day deadline that they want to
serve up some sort of uh positive story
for Russia because most analysts have
been rather shocked and surprised at how
long uh this has taken Russia so people
have overestimated the Russian military
military it has been acting very
chaotically and now they can just focus
on donbass but of course the ukrainians
have a great deal of experience there
they've been at War for eight years and
as you noted uh Charles Michelle the
president of the European Council is
visiting Kiev today uh signaling
Europe's
interests in the region but the whole
issue about sanctions uh is kind of
symbolic in many respects some sanctions
do have teeth we're seeing that the
Russian economy is really taking a hit
but the the key issue is energy and for
example Germany is almost half reliant
on their supplies from Russia so I think
that uh the fact that they're still not
talking about gas doesn't show that
they're very serious about that because
they're worried about the inflationary
pressures in Europe in addition to that
individual member states can cut
Reliance on Russian gas as we've seen
with Lithuania which now has zero
Imports of Russian guests so they don't
need all for the whole EU with 27 member
states it's very difficult to get
everyone to agree you have some
countries like Hungary who are more
pro-russian than other countries so it
would be difficult for them to all work
together they might water down the
sanctions but then there are other types
of symbolic sanctions like on caviar
which is just a small small portion of
exports to Europe so I think that the
Europeans uh you know they do a lot of
virtue signaling but I think that there
is a growing wariness about what's
really happening uh in Ukraine we've
seen millions of refugees flee to Europe
and as the other commentator noted this
is a very serious war and we're also
seeing other effects of unintended
consequences of Russia's Putin's
behavior for example both Sweden and
Finland are looking like they will join
NATO we're going to talk about we're
going to talk about those uh those moves
towards joining NATO a little bit uh
later and what that might mean for
security calculations in Europe I'd like
to come back to you Pavel falgenhauer
because I don't think we've really
answered this question yet what is the
significance of the donbass region for
President Putin well Russia has been
supporting the
pro-russian separatists there in Donetsk
and wogans for since uh 2014 before this
campaign began Russia recognized
officially the independence of these to
statewoods and actually the official
reason for going into Ukraine has been
the need to defend them and expand their
territory to the administrative pre-war
territories of the Uganda and that's
oblast so now they're trying to do that
apparently
but again there's this talk about the
main line that one I don't believe that
there is a deadline it's not there is no
deadline at all the the thing is the
Russia is caught in a very in a very
serious situation and will try to do its
best to break out of it but the and so
May 9 does not play much of a role
there's going to be a parade in Moscow
and okay but that's it
um right now Russia and and Ukraine are
in the mid-season situation the winter
campaign is over the summer campaign did
not begin the ground is still a bit wet
there was a lot of rain so right now
actually the advances will be very slow
by definition because you have to still
rely on paved roads which in the Don
boss are very narrow not many of them in
a very bad state so both sides are
preparing for decisive battle in the
summer campaign all right and that's
right now what will be jockeying for
positions who's going to occupy the
better position for the decisive battle
which I begin that will happen in May
maybe in June Helena yachenko talking
about the East about donbass it's been
almost eight years since they
self-declared themselves as republics
it's been described since then as
becoming totalitarian it's like right
okay it's like will you give me your
perspective right please once again
these people were
going to referendum
uh with being forced by Russian soldiers
who came to our land who came to a
sovereign country which Ukraine is and
what in 2014 and they forced people to
go to fake referendum so please don't
use Putin narrative don't use Narrative
of Russian Nazis and don't say that uh
Ukrainian territory claims themselves to
be you know Russian territories or
independent terrorists I call them
self-declared and you're declared they
are not self-declared right they are not
self-declared okay right they are
terrorists and separatists right so
please don't use Russian narrative
because I hope that you are Independent
Media and no Kremlin Media or Russian
media right
is that is is that uh the guy uh the
Russian guy who just talked is uh was
talking about you know a kind of winter
campaign summer campaign but he forgot
to mention that there is spring campaign
it's a planting campaign a campaign when
Ukrainian Farmers when Ukrainian
agriculture companies appointing food
which will grow in Summer and Autumn and
I want to tell you I want actually to to
finally knock to your heart and your
minds with information
that what Russians are doing in Ukraine
is atrocity but not only to Ukrainian
people to Ukrainian mothers and
Ukrainian children but also they are
doing horrible things to all Arabic
World okay I will sure
please no excuse me my role in this my
role in moderating is to ensure that we
have an even conversation or more
panelists have the opportunity to share
the same amount of air time so I'm sorry
I'm going to have to pass on over to our
analyst in Europe Teresa how do you
think this is going to play out is the
East going to come under Russia's sphere
of influence is that is it going to be
annexed
in the fog of war no one has made any
correct predictions at all in this war
and I would say that
it's really unclear no one would predict
half of the things that have happened in
Ukraine so I will not make any
predictions on this they are adding more
troops in the region we know Russians
have a huge morale problem and this
could and the ukrainians have fought
very hard because it's their country and
it's their land so it's very difficult
at this moment to predict what will
happen will be a turning point as lavrov
has stated it's phase two uh but I think
that
uh the European response to all of this
needs to be more uh weapons more support
more sanctions and more money we see
Germany kind of dragging their heels on
all of this President zielinski of
Ukraine has begged for uh leopard tanks
from Germany but there's a lot of
reluctance to do this a new Scandal just
erupted recently in Europe about uh the
spd's ties to gas prom the Russian gas
company so the corruption the octopus of
Russian corruption reaches not just to
London grad as everyone calls London
where where it's known for washing the
laundry you know being the laundromat
for Russian oligarchs money but we see
this in Germany that the biggest country
in Europe
um the strongest economy and they have
such close ties to Russia uh we see that
it has hubbled any initiatives to have
sanctions meaningful sanctions on guests
now they're trying to Cobble together
some sanctions on Russian oil that has
been delayed for quite some time but
they're trying to iron that out so I
think that Europe really needs to take
these things seriously I know it's big
and unwieldy and very hard to get these
things done they do a lot of virtue
signaling and symbol but I think that we
understand that there will be spillage
uh that Ukraine might not just be the
only uh it might just be an appetizer if
we look at the agreements or the draft
agreements that Putin tables back in
December that this means more than
Ukraine the baltics are fearful central
eastern European member states are very
fearful so I think that Putin has
inadvertently given NATO its mojo back
but Pavel falgenhauer there have been
war crimes documented there has been an
opening of an investigation into
possible alleged war crimes uh the
stories as we've been hearing for weeks
now are are horrendous these these just
atrocities as we've been discussing do
you believe that Russia will
I guess be held to account or or that
these will be fully investigated
uh well I believe they're going to be
investigated but not in Russia right now
the Moscow is rejecting outright no
that's the kind of traditional position
has happened with the murder of the
Polish officers in 1940 and was a Russia
denied any responsibility to the Soviet
Union collapsed together with communist
rule so I'd only think right now Russia
is going to cooperate uh well Putin
promised apparently to the Austrian
Chancellor that Russia would cooperate
but I don't think that that's going to
happen of course in the future if there
is I don't know regime change in Moscow
there these crimes could be actually
tried in court maybe maybe even in
Moscow I don't know but that's very much
in the future it's not immediate right
now and it doesn't have right now that
much bearing on the city situation in
the field though of course in the it's a
it's a terrific uh PR disaster for uh
Moscow and I believe the
very high serious things that have been
done by Russian soldiers and apparently
by their commanders were working the
other direction uh I'm not sure that
this was a political intent but anyway
the result is disastrous
but nothing is going to be done about it
okay I'd like to come back to you Helena
yochenko how do you think this is going
to play out what are your I guess
concerns for the coming weeks and months
for your country
if Russians don't put down their weapon
and leave our sovereign country the
situation not only in Ukraine but also
in the world and in Arabic world as well
will be deteriorating the situation will
be worse and worse
and uh there will be a very serious
problem with food and with uh food
Security in Arabic world as well yeah
whereas you know Ukraine's Ukraine
agriculture Ukrainian food Ukrainian
sunflower oil but also wheat and other
agricultural role products are feeding
Arabic world as well 42 percent of
Ukrainian export was Agriculture and
food so if this year and next year
Arabic world will have no agriculture
from Ukraine if Agricultural Product
will go the price for agricultural
products will go high you know who to
blame you should blame Russia you should
blame Russian army and you should blame
Putin because they invaded our country
and they don't let us to have a proper
plant or you know a plant campaign we
are unable to plant food for the whole
world but I think we're already 1600
million people 600 million people in the
world are dependent on Ukrainian food I
know we're already seeing these Rises
around the world right we're already
seeing skyrocketing costs of basic goods
for many people around the world we're
coming nearly to the end of the program
uh I'd like to go back to uh Teresa
Fallon just to round out the show here
um when the war first started the stand
with Ukraine sort of symbol it was
everywhere do you think that as time
goes on the world's resolve the West's
resolve to help Ukraine May filter I
mean that's a very good question you
know the national community's attention
span is very limited so I think that
moves like today uh president of the
European Council Charles Michelle's
visit to Kiev keeps it on the the map
for many people but I can see even in
the news cycle we don't see it on the
front page so much anymore the story of
Ukraine so I think the Russians
understand that and I also we all know
that the Warren donbath has been going
on for eight years and it didn't really
get onto the headlines until this recent
indication of Ukraine so for eight years
this has been linked you know this has
been a long drawn out conflict and so
this is my concern but on the other hand
now we're seeing because of this kind of
distraction with Ukraine uh Sweden and
Finland are are looking like they are
going to ask to join NATO so I think
that individually Sweden and Finland
they wouldn't have considered it but
because they saw you know they're not
really fearful of Russia so much anymore
they see the military not as frightening
as they had in the past they see it as
incompetent and chaotic and so joining
together Sweden and Finland appear to be
uh
gaining more momentum to join NATO so
there's a NATO Summit in June so this is
something that will be moving forward
and today in the often blood it's a
Swedish newspaper uh there was a very
positive editorial by the editorial
board supporting Sweden's uh membership
of NATO which is really a watershed
moment because for 200 years Sweden has
been a neutral country so for them to
join with Finland uh
the idea that you know this germinating
idea of joining NATO uh full member
status because they do have very close
cooperation with NATO at this point but
they would be covered by Article 5 so
that would transform the landscape the
security landscape of Europe and I think
that Russia has really misplayed its
hand it has changed the Strategic
landscape of Europe in ways that they
had never intended all right and I think
that this of the effects my apologies we
have run over time uh we will have to
leave it there uh thank you very much
for joining us uh Helena ichenko
falgenhauer and Teresa Fallon and thank
you two for watching you can see the
program again anytime by visiting our
website Al jazeera.com and for the
discussion go to our Facebook page
that's facebook.com forward slash AJ
Inside Story you can also join the
conversation on Twitter our handle is at
AJ inside story from me canvanell the
entire team here in Doha bye for now
foreign
[Music]